Where I come from
it takes courage
to become an independent journalist.
Most media outlets in Russia work under censorship
and it’s harder from year to year to speak
freely
regardless of the issues.
Three months after the assassination of my
father Boris Nemtsov,
a Russian opposition politician,
I came to Berlin to deliver a speech
about freedom of the press.
And on the same day I decided to leave Russia.
For me, it was a step towards freedom.
The most direct association with Germany is
freedom
and I strongly believe that it is the necessary
precondition
for creativity and, ultimately, progress.
My life in Germany started here
just 100 meters from the Brandenburg Gate
a symbol of unity that used to represent division.
And I still have hope
that the current period of tensions
between Russia and Europe will come to an end.